kind of buzz I try to see what you see
okay so this drill here is this one
right but I taking away my any
[Music]
self-deceiving breaks mangles okay bye
like my base is triangular now and not
rectangular okay so you can do this
drill like you do the other one the lock
your lock your posture out level-1
level-2 start to relax okay
circular laughs everything and then when
you can I'm going to bring him to my
chest and I keeping the same feeling in
here as I had when my hand was out there
and I am trying to relax so he should
feel me relaxing my chest right and but
he's not pushing me back when I'm ready
when I think I have that good feeling
you I will get his other hand put it on
and I will continue relaxing and he will
keep pushing
okay let's try it back so just like in
the standing thrill as you bring them on
the reason I'm happy to do this is so
you try to bring your mind out of here
and what does this feel like when I hold
up in space
okay then try to keep that feeling here
okay then I want you to practice this
relaxing releasing that's the drill
we're doing now
I keep releasing releasing but you'll
notice is your dog your abdomen will
start to swell with pressure as you're
releasing releasing releasing then
you're going to ask for more pressure
and you get to practice more releasing
as that triggers you so this
give-and-take of pressure trigger
release pressure triggers my mind and I
release as I release I'll start to swell
in my abdomen and as I'm doing all this
I don't want you to brace like that and
I don't want you to brace with your
spine okay so he's pushing and I'm just
releasing and I will just want to make
this point
so as I'm here like that I feel like I'm
I'm leaning backwards right I don't
really need what you guys think do you
see how I'm doing that you guys are
thinking like that okay
so I'm not asking you to do that drill
but I'm asking you not to not to brace
okay I'm not holding on to anything
I just practicing this releasing you
don't try to slow your abdomen your
abdomen abdomen swells as you
mr. releasing okay let's try it let's
let's think about it a little different
a little different so as he comes in
when you look like you guys are thinking
this I'll be able to break what I'm
actually doing is his pout his power to
push is being neutralized so his and I
don't know why it works but his his he
can really start to uh push and I'm I'm
thinking about stealing that power
[Music]
as opposed to being so stable
he can't okay and I think when I feel it
he reminds me of corpse pose so when you
do course pose
you're gonna consciously release the
tension do you get it and when you do
chorus pose sometimes you notice my
shoulders will finally drop but after
you do close close for a while you
realize I don't I can have the release
without the lose having to move a
certain way so I can keep my limbs here
but I am releasing inside because if I
do this like this
and if you'll if you notice when he's
here I am trying to brace on him okay I
can't even take out watch his body when
I when I drop you see how he came in a
little okay but he's not coming in
because my shoulders round forward like
that okay I would just keep the same
posture but I'm releasing the facts
and more than that I'm releasing the
desire to stand up okay
do you understand so just think I'll you
know your shoulders don't need to do
this for me to relax I can just release
the tension as they are in this state
right here okay got that
all right let's try thinking about it
this way yeah hey okay so now what I
want to do is we were doing like yo like
horse pose that kind of slow conscious
releasing right okay now we're going to
do it a little quicker so writing comes
in release you'll feel the push you'll
feel the trigger and you release it okay
[Music]
and you can do the other hand quicker
and not release okay so maybe you'll get
like three releases comes in boom
release release and see how I felt that
when it came did you feel that okay then
he'll do the other one and I'll do it as
quick as I can
so you can start out with the hand and
then you bring it here and it'll be a
release did you see this hips move then
he'll come in and he'll do another one
and I'm just releasing quicker rather
than the slow conscious and trying to
get quick release quick releases right
at contact so you gotta push you to push
right it goes right to a quick one
[Music]
don't go getting going you gotta do it
like this with your fingertips
okay and then your weight comes down
your palms
okay so when his weight comes on his
palms he gets a release immediately
covers up this is different he goes go
see it see it different he goes and get
some sort
yeah
an easier is driving into okay he goes
okay let's try that I think that's a
good girl where those are able to
consciously relax now consciously
relaxed of the timing that is coming in
okay so but if you're here then you're
here and you're just doing it as slow as
you need to be to keep release so once
you get the release going what you are
should notice is that he's he is stuck
to me so when I move I'm not going like
that so he's here and now he's stuck to
me wherever I go he he will move you see
that it's not because I'm going like
that like that you see he's just driving
he's driving I'm releasing and I can
move okay so maybe you had some micro
tension in your hips this is going to
see if you if you got rid of then you
should be able to keep this absorption
hey easy I'm doing that so we'll try
we'll go here or you'll start here he'll
go absorb and move let's turn it again
then you go to the other way absorb and
you'll move okay
please understand that it's different
for me moving out of the way he's here
and we're stuck so when I move he moves
you get it okay
let's try that gift even did you get a
good look at it
okay okay I go there's my drill release
and you'll feel his stuff
[Music]
push
are you going here bring it in in your
seat keeping this feeling get it lock it
release you could do it with one hand to
release won't release then you'll feel
like oh yeah we are stuck and if I try
to move him with bracing right you'll
see that that's not it I can't I can't
bring that shoulder about what I can
when I release okay try